Speaker 1: There is a stunning new report
out of Politico that officials in Palm Beach,
Florida, are actively contingency planning
for a possible indictment of former President
Donald Trump by Manhattan District Attorney
Cy Vance Jr., which could happen while Donald
Trump is at his Florida club, Mar a Lago.
That this is even something being gamed out
by Palm Beach officials is stunning.
The sources here are two high ranking county
officials from Palm Beach involved in these
planning sessions.
The real legal question is that of extradition
from Florida to New York in the event of a
New York indictment of Trump.
Now, what's ironic or tragic or I don't know
what to call it, is that because of an obscure
Florida statute about interstate extradition,
it would basically come down to the Florida
governor, who currently is the pro Trump Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis, who could ultimately
decide to intervene and do an investigation
of his own to determine whether the indicted
person should be extradited to another state.
Joe Abruzzo, clerk of the Circuit Court of
Palm Beach.
And he says, quote, The statute leaves room
for interpretation that the governor has the
power to order a review and potentially not
comply with the extradition notice.
Now, on the other hand, Trump is currently
moving from Mar a Lago in Florida to his Bedminster,
New Jersey, estate for the summer.
If a New York City indictment came down with
Trump and Jersey, it's a different ballgame.
There's also a statute there allowing the
governor to intervene.
But the governor in New Jersey is Democrat
Phil Murphy, not a Trump sycophant brownnoser
would likely just not get involved at all.
And if Trump were in New Jersey at the time
of the indictment, Trump likely would be extradited
to New York.
So there's multiple layers here to consider.
First of all, imagine a former president getting
indicted period would be one of the biggest
news stories in American political history,
period.
Second, imagine if former President Trump
is indicted and he's in Florida and Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis refuses to extradite
Trump.
Consider what that would mean in terms of
the legal insanity of a governor protecting
a former president from extradition on an
indictment and that Trump would essentially
become a fugitive in his own country, at least
to his native New York, and likely wouldn't
be able to travel to New York on the risk
of arrest.
Now, I think that while de Santos would plot
plausibly intervene, there are plenty of Republican
officials who love the idea of Trump and an
indictment as a way to finally get Trump out
of the way and try to commandeer Trump's very
constituents for themselves.
These would be the Republicans who publicly
still stand by Trump, but probably privately
think he's an idiot and bad for the Republican
Party.
Could Ron DeSantis even try to intervene?
But in exchange for something, imagine dissent
is going to Trump and saying I'll intervene
to stop the extradition, but then you owe
me.
And what I want is for you not to run in 2024
and to endorse me for president in twenty
twenty four, I don't know.
But Trump being stuck in Florida without being
able to leave is already pretty rich.
Having to endorse the guy that saves him would
be a just delightful possibility.
Now, do I think any of this will happen?
Very unlikely.
I know we've all thought about that perp walk,
that potential moment where Donald Trump is
handcuffed and walked in front of the cameras.
But that is so far from a real possibility.
Even if Trump were indicted, he wouldn't be
perp walked.
It would all be very quiet.
And quite frankly, I think it's all very far
fetched.
But the fact that it's potentially real enough
that officials around the country are thinking
about if Trump is indicted, how do we handle
it?
That's already historic.
And it is absolutely stunning that it's the
discussion Monday, Memorial Day.
We are doing a one day membership special.
OK, this is what we call a single day membership
bomb.
If you want to get in on a membership, including
all of the great benefits, as well as the
world famous award winning bonus show Monday,
Memorial Day is a beautiful day to do it.
Just get on my newsletter, go to David Pakman
Dotcom upper right of the website.
You type in your email address, you get on
my newsletter Monday, Memorial Day.
You'll get an email telling you exactly how
to take advantage of this special.
Quick break.
Back after this